[Music]
thank you
one of the key aspects that is running
throughout Philip K Dick's alternate
history novel The Man in the High Castle
is the interconnection between the
dominant Nazi regime which controls
roughly half of the world after the
conquest by the Axis powers and various
forms of insanity some of which can
interlock with each other and evil evil
not just in the sense of being an evil
person but doing great evil continuing
replicating evil and all three of these
are folded into each other interestingly
the only character that we get any
reflections of who is German about this
matter is Rudolph Wegner the Opera Naval
intelligence operative who is bringing
the news of a horrible plot lot on the
part of the Nazis operation dandelion
which will involve the use of nuclear
weapons against the Japanese home
islands and the subsequent conquest of
the Japanese co-prosperity sphere none
of the other Germans in the story are
able to have any sort of insight about
this with the exception perhaps of a
character who we originally think is
Italian he's not actually German he's
actually Swiss so perhaps he is also a
exception in this case and we get a lot
of music on the part of the other
American and Japanese characters so we
begin
really in chapter 2 with Robert
children's musings and children himself
is not particularly you could say
condemnatory of the Nazis or the
Japanese for that matter he's sort of an
accommodator he uh tells himself one had
to blame the Germans for the situation
tendency to bite off more than they
could chew after all they'd barely
managed to win the war and at once
they'd gone off to conquer the solar
system while at home they'd passed
edicts well at least the idea was good
and after all they'd been successful
with the Jews and Gypsies and Bible
students and the Slavs have been rolled
back 2 000 years worth of their
Heartland in Asia and so we see him
reflecting on this and being like well
you know they're actually not that bad
right
and then we also see this again in his
discussion with the Japanese couple
later on but then we get to Africa
they'd simply let their enthusiasm get
the better of them there and you had to
admire that although more thoughtful
advice sort of questioned them to
perhaps wait a little bit until for
instance project Farmland had been
completed there the Nazis had shown
genius right and so he's he's actually
seeing uh the Nazi efforts just just
going too far with things too
enthusiastic
but
when we get to chapter three
and Juliana is thinking about the Nazis
we get a very different point of view
so she thinks to herself you know
there's no way that we could actually go
to colonies and space they wouldn't let
me and Joe in that's how the Nazis are
they're not idealists like Joe and me
they're cynics with utter Faith it's
sort of a brain defect like a lobotomy
that maiming those German psychiatrists
do as a poor substitute for
Psychotherapy and then she goes on
further and she has some other
interesting thoughts that have to do
essentially with stunted sexuality and
incest their trouble she decided is with
sex they did something foul with it back
in the 30s and it's gotten worse Hitler
started it with his what was she his
sister Aunt niece and the family was
inbred already his mother and father
were cousins they're all committing
incest going back to the original sin of
lusting for their own mothers that's why
they those of Elite SS fairies have that
Angelic simper that blonde baby-like
innocence they're saving themselves for
Mama or for each other then who is Mama
for them she wondered the leader
the hero Borman who's supposed to be
dying or the sick one and here she
reflects on Adolf Hitler
old Adolf supposed to be in a sanitarium
somewhere living out a life of senile
paresis syphilis of the brain dating
back to his poor days as a bomb in
Vienna obviously it was God sardonic
Vengeance right out of some silent movie
The awful man struck down by internal
filth the historic plague for man's
wickedness and then she reflects okay so
that would be bad by itself right maybe
Hitler deserves that sort of end but the
problem was the horrible part was that
the present-day German Empire was a
product of that brain first a political
party then a nation then half the world
and the Nazis themselves had diagnosed
it identified it that quack herbal
medicine man who treated Hitler he that
he goes on or she goes on the entire
world knew it and yet the leader's
gabble was still sacred still holy writ
their views had infected a civilization
by now and like evil spores uh the blind
blonde Nazi queens were swishing out
from Earth to the other planets
spreading the contamination what you get
for incest Madness blindness death so a
much more
pejorative view right tracing it back to
sexuality and following a screwed up
leader
I think we get a more mature uh
treatment in terms of tagomi and tagomi
here is talking with Baines who's
actually Rudolph Wegner
and he carries out some comparisons and
wants uh Wagner's view on it he says
that you know we ourselves have not
solved the problem of the Aged more of
which persons occur constantly as
medical measures improve China teaches
us rightly to honor the old but the
Germans cause our neglect to seem close
to outright virtue I understand they
murder the old so the Chinese culture is
offering a model the Japanese are not
quite living up to it but they're
certainly not as bad as the Nazis when
it comes to this and he says
what's your point of view Mr Baines
towards the old the sick the feeble the
insane the useless in all all variations
and what tagomi's getting at here
is how we value human beings
he says of what uses a newborn baby I've
committed that utterance and into memory
and contemplate it many times there is
no use
and then he asks isn't it true that no
man should be the instrument for
another's needs and what he's suggesting
here is something like human dignity
right respecting other human beings as
human beings and we can draw great
contrast between the Japanese are
certainly not angels but they're
certainly not as evil as the Nazis in
this respect
um we also find tagomi having some very
interesting reactions there's sort of a
review of the possible candidates for
Nazi leadership and tagumi as he's
hearing this actually has to leave the
room because he's feeling physically ill
he's feeling revulsion disgust
nausea about this
and why well when he's talking with the
non-ferrous or man
afterwards he says this is what that guy
says
it's a sleight of hand business their
uses of atomic energy have kept things
together and the diversion of their
circus-like Rocka travel to Mars and
Venus they've they've yielded nothing of
economic worth and then tagomi says they
are dramatic and then the non-ferrous
ore man says his prognosis was gloomy he
feels that most high-placed Nazis are
review refusing to face facts Visa V
their economic plight by doing so they
tend to accelerate their the the the
tendency towards greater Tour De Forest
Adventures less predictability less
stability in general the cycle of manic
enthusiasm than fear then parte
Solutions of a desperate type the point
he got across is that this tends to
bring the most irresponsible and
Reckless aspirants to the top so we must
presume that the worst rather than the
best choice will be made the sober and
responsible elements will be defeated in
the present Clash so you know there's
there's leadership and the leaders
themselves some of them are fairly sane
some of them are completely crazy and
The Crazy Ones are going to rise to the
top in chapter 10 I mentioned in that we
have this character Joe who is
supposed to be Italian and actually very
invested in his role as a former Italian
which he wasn't he's actually Swiss he's
actually an SD Commando
but he goes on this rant
uh spoken like a devout fascist Juliana
thanks right
and he says I'm not an intellectual
fascism has no need of that what is
wanted is the deed Theory derives from
action what are corporate State demands
from us is comprehension of the social
forces of History you see I tell you I
know Juliana his voice his tone is
earnest almost beseeching those old
rotten money-run Empires Britain and
France and the USA though the latter
actually a sort of bastard side shoot
not strictly Empire but money oriented
even so they had no soul and so
naturally no future no growth Nazis a
bunch of street thugs I agree you agree
right
and then he says
um I'm skipping ahead a little bit here
because he's talking about Robinson and
His his book and he goes on and he says
did you ever read what the duche wrote
inspired beautiful man beautiful writing
explains the underlying actuality of
every event real issue in war was old
versus new money that's why Nazis drag
Jewish question mistakenly into it
versus communal Mass Spirit what Nazis
called gamind shaft fulkness like
Soviets the commune right only the
Communists sneaked in pan Slavic Peter
the Great Empire Ambitions along with it
made social reform means for Imperial
Ambitions Juliana thought like Mussolini
did exactly Nazi thuggery a tragedy Joe
stuttered away but change is always hard
on the loser nothing new look at
previous revolutions such as French or
Cromwell against Irish too much
philosophy in Germanic temperament too
much theater too all those rallies you
never find true fascists talking only
doing like me right and then she says
God you've been talking a mile a minute
and he shouts excitedly I'm explaining
fascist theory of action she couldn't
answer it was too funny but the man
beside her did not think it was funny he
glowered at her his face red veins in
his forehead became distended and he
began once more to shake and again he
passed his fingers clutchingly along his
scalp forward and back not speaking only
staring at her so Joe is kind of an
interesting comparison here the Nazis
screwed things up they made things about
you know race rather than about real
Community there's all sorts of other
ways in which the Italians the fascist
had it better but he's crazy too isn't
he just in a somewhat different way
in chapter 14
we take up to gomi again and here we see
something really interesting happening
something that has been ripening within
tagomi throughout this this thing he's
able to confront one of the Nazis who he
has to deal with Council rice after the
SD attack on the Nippon Times building
where tagomi himself proves himself a
sort of hero killing two of the SD men
having to be reintegrated afterwards
and the key theme Here
is that he tells the Nazis you are evil
you are embroiled and evil the right
response to this is to repent to change
so he says your nation is about to
descend into greater vileness than ever
you know the hexagram the abyss speaking
as a private person not as a
representative of a Japanese official
dumb I declare my heart is sick with
horror a bloodbath is coming beyond all
compare yet even now you strive for some
egotistic gain or goal and he goes on of
the malady growing these long years but
which entered viral informed the day I
heard helplessly your leaders Escapade
recited anyhow therapeutic possibility
nil for you too sir in language of
Goodman Mather of proper properly
recalled
repent
so the council doesn't take that
seriously he wants to you know restore a
kind of normalcy and tagumi is saying
you are involved with evil you can't
even be healed with therapy something
has to change and it doesn't right
the last person who we have to bring up
is somebody we've mentioned already
Rudolph Wagner traveling as Baines
Baines gets into a confrontation in
chapter three with this German artist
lutza right and he thinks to himself
some very important Reflections about
insanity
he says am I racially kin to this man so
closely that for all intents and
purposes it is the same then it's in me
too The Psychotic streak a psychotic
world we live in the Mad Men are in
power how long have we known this face
this and how many of us do know it not
Lotsa perhaps if you know you're insane
then you're not insane or you are
becoming sane finally waking up I
suppose only a few are aware of this
isolated persons here and there but the
broad masses what do they think do they
imagine they live in a same world or do
they glimpse
guess the truth
and then he thought to himself what does
it mean insane a legal definition what
do I mean I feel it see it but what is
it
he thought it's something they do
something they are it is their
unconsciousness their lack of knowledge
about others they are not aware of being
what they do to others the destruction
they caused and are causing no he
thought that isn't it I don't know I
sense it I Intuit it but they are
purposely purposelessly cruel is that it
no gaudy thought I can't find it make it
clear do they ignore parts of reality
yes
and now we get to the realization but
it's more
it is their plans yes their plans their
conquering a planet something frenzied
and demented as was their conquering of
Africa and before that Europe and Asia
and now he puts his finger on it it's
not just like depraved sexuality it's
not just some sort of you know getting
things wrong here and there
says their view is Cosmic not of a man
here a child here but an abstraction
race land folk land blut era not of
Honorable Men but era itself honor the
abstract is real the actual is invisible
to them
but not good men this good man it is
their sense of space and time and so
he's going on and he's saying that they
are thinking in terms of abstractions
and then he identifies one other key
element of this
they want to be the agents not the
victims of History they identify with
God's power and believe they are Godlike
that is their basic Madness they are
overcome by some archetype their egos
have expanded psychotically so they
cannot tell where they begin and the
godhead leaves off it's not hubris not
Pride it is inflation of the ego to its
ultimates
confusion between him who worships and
that which is worshiped and there's this
amazing line here man has not eaten God
God has eaten man
and then he says what they don't
comprehend is man's helplessness
we should be noticing this that would
make us actually sane and we see similar
thoughts in chapter 15 as Wagner is
arriving in Germany thinking about you
know well did I accomplish anything you
know I can't be optimistic and then he
thinks
suppose eventually the Nazis destroy it
all they just they leave everything a
sterile Ash that may be what they're
craving actively seeking a final
Holocaust for everyone
and uh as he's he's Landing he's
thinking to himself about this then he
gets taken in by the uh SS people and he
asks them about what's going on there
and his reflection of this he says it
goes on the internicine hate perhaps the
seeds are there and that they will eat
each other at last and leave the rest of
us here and then in the world still
alive still enough of us wants more to
build and hope and make a few simple
plans so there's perhaps an out if the
insanity of the Nazis can be turned in
on itself to where they destroy each
other rather than destroying the rest of
the world so we have a lot of
interesting Reflections and experiences
here about the virulence you could say
of not only the Nazi ideology but it's
practice it's people it's
exemplifications the kinds of activities
and mad plans that the Nazi regime and
its agents will engage in and we see
that this is a theme running throughout
this entire work
put into the not necessarily words but
the thoughts of so many of the
characters who are not Nazis